ok let's check out some interesting
discussions from the David Pakman show
subreddit about 8000 of our viewers and
listeners regularly participating in
discussion and debate of newsworthy and
compelling topics at david pakman.com
slash read it one interesting post that
i noticed this morning asks what happens
after trump
going further in saying if trump ever is
charged with a serious crime what
happens to the decisions he has made in
the last two years if he gained the
presidency illegally shouldn't anything
he's had a major part in deciding be
rolled back to the previous position
whether it's the Paris climate Accord or
anything else the answer is of course
absolutely yes if Donald Trump achieved
the presidency illegally then the things
he did during that time should be rolled
back but they're not going to be Brett
Kavanaugh is on the Supreme Court for
life
Neil Gorsuch is on the Supreme Court for
life so my advice merely to not drive
yourself nuts is to forget about that
because it's not going to happen we need
to do what we can to ensure that there
are consequences for the crimes that
have been committed but put out of your
mind the idea of undoing everything that
has been done by the Trump
administration because it's just not
going to happen
also from the david pakman show
subreddit this morning new study
suggests North Korea is secretly
developing its military technology via
open scientific research in order to
circumvent sanctions yes
so I don't think it will come as a
surprise to anybody that even though
there were the equivalent of victory
parades victory tweets I guess we can
call them by Trump and his
administration after that Singapore
summit with Kim jong-un the North Korean
leader nothing appears to be changing
when it comes to nuclear development
everything appears to be moving forward
there is no evidence at this time that
North Korea has suspended any of what
they're doing and nobody's talking about
it anymore I guess I mean is it do we
think Pat that Trump is still consider
the North Korea summit a victory for
Trump even though he did it nothing
changed and now no one talks about it
anymore do they see that as an
accomplishment
well we suspected this this is how it
would go because we could take a look at
history and see that North Korean
leaders dealt with previous presidents
in the same way sometimes would give him
lip service but then nothing would come
of it
I think the Trump supporters were
actually convinced though that this time
would be different and they were proven
wrong this time it was all gonna happen
yep I think you're absolutely right and
it's sad and nobody's talking about it
anymore because there's like five new
scandals every single week lastly a very
odd post from the David Pakman show
subreddit saying what's the best way to
challenge David Pakman to a fight of
course my last name misspelled in this
post it was hard to tell Pat from this
weather they're saying what's the best
way to challenge me to a physical fight
or just like how can they argue with me
about politics
probably a physical fight otherwise they
would say argument debate how can I call
in and talk to David type of thing very
strange yeah I don't know let's assume
you could challenge me to a fight and I
accepted how would the outcome of that
fight really prove anything or determine
anything about what our politics should
be I don't really get it
join the discussion david pakman.com
slash r-e